it keeps loading twitch and then it
keeps disconnecting from twitch and
loading twitch and disconnecting from 2h
maybe we should do this on youtube next
time we'll see so J reyez well could you
tell a clip in here what's in my cup
yeah I know you got some vitamin water
from me me Nina needy me I love that I'm
gonna have to tell her that one Nene I
don't know that she's been I don't know
she's been called Nene before I like it
it's interesting okay uh okay I'll be
back Junior eyes the same as backup you
guys seen it or bad you're seeing it
everybody's seeing it you can hear me
okay let me pick my mighty mo team Omid
as requested by rishi cup okay
good we're good okay i I'm just
refreshing the say that year could I
want to make sure that we're yeah I'm
ready so it's still kind of frozen
people saying there's a lot of lag
mm-hmm I think it's a stream I have a
lot of like to hmm let me maybe close a
few windows see if that makes a
difference i don't know what's on our
end or the weak side was that was that
close that sad
who's that all right let me just pop in
here how is it now guys
still I do hmm
can you hear us okay maybe fix now let's
see only audio for me only audio what do
you think well we only get to hear Rishi
anyway maybe we should do an all audio
version and podcast it up a little bit
the podcast version the podcast version
listen as long as the audio is going
through we can deliver some wisdom Jay
rises saying it's working i'm on the
reloads yeah okay here we go so this
will be a this is this is gonna be fun
team Omid again I don't know why I keep
getting mid mid is the hardest it's the
most it's the most not the hardest role
it's the most popular role so it's the
hardest to get mmm well that's the one
that you played and you did really well
this week on it yes I did I got lucky on
that one we'd be eight okay okay so
let's uh let's there's trainer six I can
hear so let's let's get to the question
what do we got okay first question today
comes from Bradley Bradley started a
blog about two weeks ago and his blog
has gotten 1300 page views but no
followers he wants to know do you have
any tips on how to get blog followers
and it's a thing so you have a blog and
getting a lot of traffic to the blog but
not able to convert to actual followers
i think this is a common problem and i
think that the most important thing i
would would say is that the content is
king that whatever people are seeing on
your page content wise
isn't enough for them to become
followers I mean that may not be the
only reason but that should be the main
focus I think in terms of prioritize and
how to start converting because at the
end of the day when the content is
providing value people will want to
continue to watch and follow and aside
from that I would say just make sure
that it's super easy for people to be
converted into followers I remember Evan
your channel when you shared what a huge
difference was made when you change the
annotation on your subscribe button and
it was previously I think it was a logo
before and then and then you turned it
into just the big bold world words click
here now or subscribe whether i should
remember this but it's like it was super
easy for people to see on that subscribe
button that this is where you go to to
subscribe so if it whether it's a pop up
on your blog or just something that
makes it easier for people to
immediately you know keep following so
the question was they had 1300 page
views but but noted subscribing to the
blog yep no followers got it yeah so oh
I can't pick right and play mid haha I'm
used to my usual built here that I can't
do because I I'm plainly differently um
super interesting um it means people are
reading one article but they don't like
it enough to want to continue on which
is which is kind of harsh right yeah uh
and so I'd be looking at I would be
curious to figure out our people going
beyond one page on the blog I got this
looking at one page and bouncing like do
you have
some really good just a really good SEO
and some really kind of click BTW titles
things that people would want to click
on but when they actually read it's not
it's not valuable like they scroll and
then and then they bounce i would
suspect that people are not visiting
multiple pages and so the content has to
the gun has to get better to reach this
point i'd be looking at how many people
are sharing your content i guess it's
something that is insta share that
people you know are tweeting it up and
emailing their friends you know you're
getting any comments on the content
blogs have kind of built in common
features that make it super easy are you
getting any of that happening you know
or not so I mean I'm in here fighting
away um that's it I just think that you
know people are not engaging with your
content enough and you're doing a good
job of attracting people so maybe have
some good SEO but you're not keeping
people so it's worth examinating not
just building great titles and having
enough you know keywords in there but
actually building something that people
want to engage with okay I mean think
about you think about your own
experience when I visit a blog and i
really like one post right like i go and
check out the homepage of the blog oh
right i mean i know what you do is you
but that's what i do i go and check out
the homepage of the block and say oh you
know this guy posted about you know
business entrepreneurship whatever
really like this one pose maybe has some
other stuff that'd be cool interesting i
do this on youtube all the time like
there's a channel that I i watch one
video love and I think about it's a
really good video I wonder what else
they have because there is a there is
with all of the different channels and
content opportunities out there there is
still a lack of quality there's there's
there's a ton of middle there's a ton of
crap but there's a lack of quality where
you just like how many channels do you
watch every single video that they put
up because
just so amazing not that many and so
when you find something that you really
love you're going to be loyal to her and
you want more of it and so I think
that's a that's a that's a common
challenge at a lot of people go through
and the common browsing experience and
so if you can fix that and you know make
better stuff then people will want to
subscribe to you like you can happen
otherwise action right like Rishi's
phone about better call to action it
definitely helped but i still had
content that people wanted to interact
with and subsea no i was still getting
subscribers before it so don't worry so
much about the conversion that you don't
do anything you know about the content
to make it better i was just going to
say what's fascinating to me as well is
that even the content that i want to
watch I can't keep up with so it's funny
because even when the content is amazing
and people want to follow every single
thing that you do you know when you're
just inundated with so many things and
everybody's got families busy lives it's
like who you know even though I know
that's my personal experience that I
can't even keep up with all the stuff
that I want to keep up with so when
you're competing with other people whose
value and content is actually that good
and even then you know those people
probably every single video or article
is not able to be followed and you know
it's not much more important that your
value and content is amazing because I
don't know I just I can't keep up with
the people I want to keep up with
sometimes yeah and yes and people have
you know people it's two people have
busy lives and people have a lot on
their plate and a lot to think about and
it just makes the
makes it all the more important that you
are putting out amazing stuff right like
I look at this happens conversation with
with Alex from 29 salsa a couple couple
of days ago maybe about a week ago where
we're looking at a Sunday class and it
was a beautiful sunny day in not as many
people showed up to the sunday classes
as you know they should have a bunch of
people missing as you want it to be on
the patio and be with their friends and
go to barbecues and picnics and all that
you know all this all this all this
summer stuff you want to do and Toronto
isn't as warm as a Nashville so we you
know we enjoy we got to take advantage
of our summer but also what it means is
that like our just our classes weren't
our classes are good enough like we're
competing with summer days and we have
to do a better job of creating not just
content but creating an experience
bringing the product that people can't
wait to come to regardless of what else
is happening in the city in the world
you know on that day and so that's
that's a big challenge and you just have
to get better
that's it I think I think this is
happening I think it's my computer I
think something's up with my computer
may be needed to be booted or something
because i'm lagging in the game but it's
not the internet connection it's just
the the i think it's related computer
tomorrow i will restart my computer
before getting into a game anyway hey I
died so that's not a good start that is
not a good start always close and then
the guy who killed me died shortly after
by my teammates oh that's some good
teamwork there but yeah this is a it's a
fun it's a fun and challenging start
it's hard when you're kind of lagging
too there's so many microseconds that
you have to pay attention to it anyway
we're here we're having fun I'm grateful
grateful to ungrateful to I'm grateful
to be here um got often to uh de masta
came back to ma stop by the house I love
it I'm not gonna reveal who the masa is
because I don't know if he wants to be
revealed but the masa is well you know
de masa is oh yeah okay all right I
don't know why I know the Mustang it I
know do mundo de masta ID okay all right
i'm curious now now you have everybody
wondering who the must is oh yeah well
allah will see if he says anything in
the chat about wanting to be revealed
all right ok moving on to the next
question Claude Roy and Claude says my
ultimate passion is for the world to go
vegan and he wants to be able to have
enough money to make a huge impact
through education raising awareness
speaking philanthropy you know he just
has a real heart for making sure that
animals are saving animals and all of
this is going to require money he
actually spoke with
a nonprofit organization as to how to
best impact in this in this way and one
of the feedback that he got from this
nonprofit was well really if you want to
make an impact in this way the best
thing to just make a lot of money and
then donate to organizations like you
know like ours I guess um and so he's
wondering because money is going to be
such a key in all of this you know
should I go back to my quote regular job
as a programmer just make a lot of money
and he'll use that to kind of help make
the impact he wants to make were you
know he's trying to get ideas of how how
he can make this happen business ideas
he's trying to figure out for himself so
but it sounds like beyond just giving
donations he just really has a passion
for wanting to speak about and educate
about it and and impact the world about
going vegan so but he needs money so
what are your thoughts is his question
all right well I well I like this I like
the passion I like that he is definitely
you know you can tell he knows his why
he's passionate about it and it isn't
about the money for him it's really
about his passion ah I think that a
great place to start would be honestly
on YouTube now hear me now that's not
going to be the way that you're gonna
make money immediately but it sounds
like you're in this cause for the long
haul and it sounds like you want to be
that person who who teaches people why
this is so important and so that's one
way of a lot of ways that you could
start getting the message out and
building a community and connecting with
other like-minded people about why vegan
is so important
in fact I think I know another channel
that has a kind of a similar message so
it'd be just a great way to start um as
far as going back to your programming
job I think there are other ways that
you can start making money without
feeling like you're going to a job that
you're not passionate about I mean it is
an option but I would say look for work
that can not only bring in money but
something that you actually enjoy and
feel like will serve this purpose it
doesn't mean you have to go work for a
vegan or a non-profit but fine to find a
job that somehow will add value to your
long-term goals yeah and just talk to as
many people as you can about possible
opportunities speaking opportunities
schools organizations that are also
interested in just start getting
yourself in the community so people know
what your mission is and you never know
what other opportunities that could
bring money could come so I i think that
uh just just try to knock on as many
doors as you can and I if you're adding
value inevitably it I think you'll get
the money that you do need to do what it
is that you are trying to do all right
um this is this is over this is is a
rough game being I'm Owen too I've died
twice it's hard when you're lagging um
so a couple things one I believe every
business should have a social cause like
every
you should be in business not just to
have a profit motive but because you're
trying to do good like the way you do
good is the way you make money is by
helping others in some way and so why
does it have to be a non-profit like why
can't you use what you're good at and
what you're interested in to to help
others and further the mission like if
he's a programmer you know does he like
programming I don't know but if he does
how can you use your programming skills
to help people become a vegan right or
help people stay vegan right like can
you design a simple program that I can
log in to our website i can go to to
track my stuff or to keep me motivated
or whatever think about the challenges
you've gone through and becoming vegan
how can you use your skills to help
further that cause and also you know
make money in the process uh I think it
should all be connected not that hey you
should go start a business or just stay
to your job just to make money and then
funnel that money to somewhere else and
that's the impact you're gonna you're
gonna have I think I think you can do a
lot better I think to the advice of just
giving money to charity I think if there
was a charity that you really loved and
really respected and really want to be a
part of then you would have already been
with them you wouldn't have wanted to
try to do your own thing like the reason
why you want to do something is because
you're frustrated with the current
experience and so the answer is going to
be just go out and give money to another
charity that's not going to make you
feel complete or whole or part of your
mission so I've been looking at using
your creative talents whether in
programming or otherwise to give back to
the cause and make money in the process
that's what I would do but I like
helping entrepreneurs it's a social
cause we I went on a right kind of about
it yesterday it's a social cause and I
make money in the process like the two
are not mutually exclusive and I think I
think that'll be your best bet
great team is fighting team is fighting
oj rise got the first tower good job Jay
okay okay whoever gets the first tower
it gives extra gold for everybody on the
team so it's a big deal Jay rises
nominated what's happening the twitch
chat' see i see people chatting as we
have anything we do too I'm not really
paying attention to it but is there
anything we need to shout out there's a
lot of there's a lot of stuff happening
yeah yeah well I was kind of giggling
we're laughing about well the Moscow
wants to remain mysterious so we're
gonna keep him on rap right now is it is
it alex is Alex de masta is he truly and
now he's over here he's trolling me all
right somebody spilled me it's all yeah
and you dumbass Alex I'm not are you
sure yeah but I'm leaching to drink my
coffee in the other room right now oh
yes yes Nina Nina went on a rampage
yesterday I'm liking you're not on video
oh I'm not oh I was waiting at the
camera okay the video is the videos down
we're lagging so we're doing a podcast
audio version relation yeah I shut down
the believe nations for a good 15 asst
yes with with a little bit of love with
wits with us oh my acting all right well
we're here the Master will remain
anonymous we'll figure out who's
trolling me here all right well let's
hit all I next question okay next
question comes from st. [ __ ] and then
James mm-hmm st. jinx says I'm trying to
improve my presentation skills and when
i recorded myself on camera it was
terrible yeah and I need your your
in-depth advice please your experience
with me
the reason I need to some of the things
that he wants to help improve is body
language fluency and speaking less
repetitious pauses and just kind of the
do's and don'ts the video recording he
was actually asking if you could make a
video about it so anyway so yeah let's
help st. jinx improve in presentation
skills all right oh I went to uh to our
what are our ADC the six trainer six
trainer six trainer six just gotta kill
are our extra guests here on the game
he's covering for me lagging and sucking
in mid so we just gotta kill bottom so
good job trailer sick all right yes yeah
nothing on camera or sucking in your
presentations mm-hmm okay so I'm
definitely still learning in this area
you know I started my youtube channel a
year and a half ago and so you know one
of the things that this best is to do it
over and over and over again practice
practice practice and watch yourself and
try to be really just intentional about
correcting the things that you don't
like one of the things that I'm
personally working on right now is my
delivery and I I've noticed that I just
have a little bit lower delivery and I
it kind of drives me insane um what does
that mean you don't know what I you talk
slower than you want to oh gosh yes it
just did yeah exactly better stead wish
it will do the opposite most people talk
too fast when they're nervous they're
trying to figure something that yeah
well for me it's something for me it's
like a couple of things is that I'm a
very high contemplate ER so I am it's
not natural for me to let anything come
out of my mouth without having
through it and and not just thought
through it but I'm weighing how will
what is coming out of my mouth affect
every single person who's listening
because i also have this part of like I
would never ever want to say something
that is purple or make someone feel bad
so because all of this process goes into
my thinking before it comes Emma now it
causes there to be a longer delivery
time so yeah and on the cup of that I
have like all this experience in
education and teaching and so I'm used
to communicating and thinking about how
is everybody in the room going to
understand what I'm saying is that makes
them so blah blah blah I take a long
time like right now to sleep something
and I see that in ideas and I I try to
correct it and I so I pick one thing
that I don't like about what I'm doing
and I practice practice practice or I
try to find someone who can take a tip
or trick on how to improve on that one
particular skill so I think I think
you're not going to be able to do
anything here on the practice that you
put into it and so you know it's not a
very glamorous answer but practice
practice practice and try to research
how to get better at the things that you
specifically feel you're not doing well
I mean there's tons of videos on body
posture body language all you needed
YouTube to probably cooked every and
everything anything and everything that
you're trying to improve I love it I saw
and twitch chat quickly that the mazda
was giving a trainer sick some love
saying good work trainer six so this is
a I'm excited too
we got we got something going my team is
definitely covering for me on this game
so ah ok we are we we both have the 12
deaths on each side is a pretty tight
game I'm hoping I can do something to
help my team out on this one um for me
it starts with expecting to suck like
expect the sock you will suck and I have
made videos on this and if you just want
if you want an example just watch my
first videos they sucked you know the
first time you try anything you're going
to suck and so to go in and think you're
gonna be amazing it's not just
unrealistic but not helpful 0 major
fight breaking out here major fight
breaking it what's going on you're gonna
do some damage we're winning ha I didn't
do a lot in that but but we killed four
of their five players and the six got a
double kill so the six is the six is
doing damage and carrying this game I
love it hey um so yeah like the first
time you do anything expect to suck
anything like you're gonna sit down and
play league of legends you're going to
suck you're going to try to go salsa
dancing you're going to suck and into
expect that you're going to be amazing
so soon is gonna really hurt your
ability to to to grow right to get the
results that you're looking for whoa big
fight another kill by the six the six is
just stepping up as this game goes on
I'm getting like more and more lag so
this is interesting I'll have to just
play super safe place super safe um and
I feel like that hurts that whole people
pack i'm doing important things in their
lives like i wanna i want to be a
snowboarder i want to be a public
speaker or whatever it is
then you try it a couple times and you
know and it's good practice like it's
great that he's you know filming himself
um that's a great start and I think the
difference is I forget who set this
there's a difference between your tastes
and your skills so the problem is he
knows what good looks like right he
knows what public speaker looks like you
we she know what a good youtuber looks
like so you have taste you know you have
good taste but you don't have the skills
yet to create what you want to create
yeah and that's frustrating so if you
know what looks good and you can't do it
then you're going to be constantly
frustrated but the end it happens to me
too like I look at Les Brown I'm like
man that Les Brown is insane I want
anything I want to speak like him and in
you know I want to keep modeling him and
I can't I like I'm not there I'm not at
that level yet but to let that now
discourage me from even trying isn't the
answer it's to keep on keep on
practicing keep on hustling keep on
getting better and I think the thing to
to compare yourself to is not not the
the ultimate so like Rishi at inova you
look up to in the YouTube space like I
want to be able to speak like that
person because right now I speak too
slowly or you know our person answering
asking the question I don't know you
want to be able to speak like on stage
that's not the person to compare
yourself to at the moment that's good
inspiration that's where you can get
that's where you can model but what you
want to compare yourself to is you
yesterday are you better than you were
young are you growing because if you're
growing those little steps every day
quickly do add up so as long as you
getting better you keep practicing
that's the path yep awesome all right
just got they know here talking about
his I'm waiting to see if he says he's
been on video because that was asking
him when is he has he been on video
because you know most of his videos are
editing like but he's not in the videos
though she's asking him is he ever going
to show up in his videos uh-huh and what
did he say uh if it is I don't plan on
being on camera any sense man come on
Xena we want to see you the world needs
me Zeno all right next question comes
from star star start mm-hmm star says
what training did you take if any to
grow your channel so fast I am
subscribed to video creators oh shut out
to Tim Schmoyer nice and that's where
she basically first saw you and learned
about your channel so she just wants to
know if you have any suggestions what
training do you have to grow your
channel go back I can't answer the seven
cuz my pic my panel ain't grown is that
yours yeah but that's not it that's
again that's not the compassion that's
not the comparison is it that is it like
your channels ahead of other peoples who
haven't you right well you're right like
I i I'm not as fast as I want to be but
I can definitely say that some people
mentioned that my growth was maybe a bit
faster for a smaller channel so my
feedback I will say is to just face it
well I didn't have training I can tell
you that but I for me in particular what
I found as far as my channel growth was
cut
a combination of putting a ton of love
into the people who did it come to my
channel because I I genuinely love
engaging in comments and engaging in
community I love community that why i
like hanging out with Willie Mason I
love community I like engaging and
talking and chatting so people came to
my channel and immediately knew that I
was going to engage with them and I
think that that was part of it but i
also think another part of it was the
advice that you gave me right in the
beginning and you said you need to put
more love into your videos and some
parsley chicken and also you know part
of what you meant by that was you know i
was when i went from one video we
survived videos a week and although i'm
not right now i'm not still at a
five-day-a-week schedule i'm getting
back to that but when i was doing five
videos a week I mean I definitely saw a
fast that's gross because people were
just seeing me more i was in people
faces more you know there was i was just
showing up more so those are two things
that I could probably review to my
faster growth love it well we're in a
big fight this is this is insane it's
insane because you have to when you're
lagging you have to kind of guess what's
going to happen and then play to what's
going to happen instead of like what is
actually happening so anyway continuing
on a big fight big fight big fight I
want at least one kill I'm not getting
anything here oh I gotta kill all right
good job right first kill first kill
okay um
I don't think you need to go to school
you know in terms of formal training
I've learned a lot from Tim as well when
I was first starting up my channel I was
obsessed with Tim's content i watched
every video him and Darrell leaves and
ne ne anything new that came out I was
all over at the dye gentleman
immediately and then that was good I
think what really helped me though was
one creating videos that I liked more
and so you need to be emotionally
connected to what you're doing you have
to be super proud of the videos you're
creating it has to be something that you
would want to show your grandkids and
something that you feel is really
missing in your life when i first
started my youtube channel it was just
for the sake of answering people's
questions kind of like what we're doing
right here you know it's just answering
people's minds and then I felt like
there was this there was this whole of
content around famous entrepreneurs and
motivational advice and I I wanted it
for myself and so I started making
videos that I would want to watch
instead of only making videos at the
audience you know like some people might
care about like even this I'm making
this for myself too like I like
answering the questions it brings me joy
but I also want to train myself and be
able to try to hand the multiple things
at once hahaha i also want to also want
to give you know opportunities to my
co-host to get some practice and
attention and awareness and i want to be
able to answer the questions of people
that are coming in and so I felt like at
the start I didn't even know really what
I was doing I didn't have like a grand
master plan and then when I started
making videos that I really felt deeply
connected to that's where everything
to really take off mm-hmm the six just
got three more kills so he's 66 is on
fire the six is yeah six is going crazy
here I like it um and then on top of
that it's just making more like making
more 21 build momentum because most of
your views will come from we're gonna
win we're gonna win GG all right I got
carried hard I got carried hard on that
game I gotta put in the chat thank you
for the carry it's it's too bad that the
people can't see the screen and what's
going on but it was major lag and I got
carried hard by my team um so you got to
do more because of related videos mostly
videos views will come from views down
the side and so the more videos you have
up the more it helps you build momentum
and so it's really hard if you're making
like a video a month it's really hard to
to to stand out or if you're practicing
you know once a month it's really hard
to stand out you got to keep it on every
single day and so I still got an S I got
it I got thank my team GG team thanks
for the carry uh the other thing it does
is the the quantity leads to the quality
like it helps you get better you know
the more the more videos you do the
better you'll get the more you practice
your speaking the better you'll get the
more you practice your editing the
better you'll get and so those two
combinations I learned yes from Tim I
learned yes from Daryl I learned yes
from Les Brown and other people but
really it comes down to making something
that I really love doing that I feel
proud of and then putting in the work to
continue improving my skills at that
craft
and if you do that then you'll see your
channel set to take off did they say the
channel but it was all about no no
information about channel okay well
that's good I mean it applies every
channel just kind of curious and check
it out mm-hmm well thank you guys for
watching I will